If your bottom navigation looks like
this or this or even this, you need to
watch this video because right now your
users are probably suffering. Every time
they open your app, they feel like this.
A bad bottom navigation doesn't just
look messy and unappealing. It makes
your app frustrating to use and
confusing to navigate. And when that
happens, users don't just get annoyed,
they leave and find something better.
But here's the good news. Fixing this is
easier than you think if you know the
right UI design principles. And today
I'm going to show you exactly how to
design a bottom navigation bar that's
not just good, but so intuitive and
smooth that people will love using your
app. These are the same design
principles used by the best apps in the
world. And by the end of this video,
you'll know exactly how to design a
bottom navbar that feels amazing. Oh,
and stick around till the end because
there's one big mistake that even pro
designers keep making. And trust me, you
don't want to be that designer. Now, one
thing that can really take your bottom
navigation to the next level is adding
subtle micro interactions like this.
Looks great, right? It's those small
details that make an app feel polished
and responsive. But before you get too
excited about animations, there's
something even more important. the
fundamentals because if you don't get
the basics right, no amount of fancy
micro interactions will save your
navigation. So, let's start from the
ground up. When you open a mobile app,
you'll usually see two types of
navigation. Top navigation, which sits
at the top, and bottom navigation, which
sits at the bottom of your screen. They
look similar on both iOS and Android.
But here's something that confuses a lot
of designers. On iOS, it's called a tab
bar. On Android, it's called bottom
navigation. Throughout this video, I'll
just call it the bottom navigation bar
to keep it simple. Now, a lot of
designers think the bottom navigation
bar is just buttons at the bottom, but
the truth is it's so much more. It's
actually the backbone of your app's
usability. Here's why. Your bottom
navigation bar represents the top level
structure of your app. It tells users
what's important and helps them move
quickly between the core sections. And
here's something you really need to
understand. This is prime real estate.
Your bottom navigation is one of the
most tapped, most used areas in your
entire app. So, every icon, every label,
every micro interaction, you have to be
strategic because a well-designed bottom
navigation can make your app feel
effortless. A bad one, it drives people
away. So, how do you decide what to put
in your bottom navigation bar? Let's
break it down step by step. Tip:
Prioritize the most important and
frequently used screens or actions. The
bottom navigation should only contain
the most essential destinations in your
app. The core features users interact
with most often. Good candidates for
bottomnav. Home, main feed, dashboard,
or landing screen. Search, discover, if
users frequently search or browse
content. Add, create, if users regularly
add posts, messages, or content.
Messages, notifications. If social
interaction is a big part of the app,
profile, user account settings, history,
and saved content. Bad candidates for
bottomnav. Help. Fact. It needs to be in
profile or side menu. Log out. No one
logs out that frequently. Keep it
elsewhere. Legal pages, privacy policy,
terms, etc. Nobody needs these at their
fingertips. Introducing elements like a
back or forward button or even logos
which are traditionally part of the top
navigation in the bottom navigation bar
is a practice best avoided. This
approach aligns with Jacob's law which
suggests that users spend most of their
time on other websites or apps.
Therefore, they prefer your site or app
to work the same way as others they
already know. Cluttering the bottom
navigation with elements typically found
at the top can confuse users as it goes
against the familiar navigation patterns
they're accustomed to. On the other
hand, including a call toaction CTA
button in the bottom navigation is a
smart move. These buttons are usually
placed in the center of prominence and
ease of access. CTAs like create an
order or post serve a dual purpose. They
stand out to the user, encouraging
action, and their central positioning
makes them easily reachable, especially
on larger devices. Tip: Understand who
are your users before you design
anything, especially your bottom
navigation. You need to know who your
users are, who's your target audience
because this will shape everything about
your design choices. Ask yourself, how
comfortable are they with technology?
How old are they? What problems are you
helping them solve? What devices do they
use? Why does this matter? Because even
small decisions like adding labels to
your icons depend on your users. If your
audience is younger and techsavvy, you
might get away with minimalist approach
and show just icons. But if your users
are older and less familiar with apps,
labels below icons can make navigation
clearer and help them feel more
confident using your app. Tip: Choose
the right sizes, padding, and margins.
Creating the right autonomy for your
bottom navigation is like crafting a
tailorade suit. It needs to fit
perfectly with the device it's designed
for. In the image, you can see detailed
properties for navigation on the iPhone
14 and iPhone 15 Pro. But these are
guidelines, not rigid rules. The key is
to adapt and experiment to find what
works best for each device. Why does
this matter? Well, on smaller devices, a
more compact navigation bar might be
more appropriate. A bulky bar can eat up
valuable screen space, making the app
feel cramped. The goal is to find the
right balance between visibility and
accessibility without overshadowing the
main content. Generally, an icon size of
24 pixels strikes a good balance. It's
large enough to be recognizable but
doesn't dominate the screen. The home
indicator, that dark bar at the bottom,
typically takes up around 34 pixels.
When it comes to labels, the sweet spot
is around 10 to 12 pixels. Smaller text
can cause accessibility issues, making
it hard for some users to read. On the
flip side, larger text can create
clutter and draw attention away from the
main content. Remember, labels are there
to guide, not to overshadow. Designing
for two to three mobile device widths is
a good practice. It ensures your
navigation bar looks great and functions
well across a range of devices. If
you're designing a bottom navigation bar
for modern smartphones, especially on
iPhones and Android devices without
physical buttons, there's one detail
that many junior designers forget. the
home indicator. That thin line at the
bottom of the screen, that's the home
indicator. It lets users swipe up to go
back to the home screen, and it sits
right below your bottom navigation bar.
So, here's what you need to know. You
should not modify or hide the home
indicator. You should not overlap your
navigation bar onto it. Why does this
matter? Because if your bottom
navigation is too low or feels cramped
against the home indicator, users might
accidentally trigger the home indicator
when trying to tap your nav icons. Find
your app harder to use, especially
one-handed. Feel like your design is
broken or unfinished. What to do
instead? Respect the devices safe area,
also called the safe zone. Make sure
your bottom navigation sits above the
home indicator so there's enough
spacing. Test it on a real device. Use
Figma Mirror to see your design directly
on your phone. What looks good in Figma
on your screen can feel completely
different when you're actually tapping
it on a real phone. Tip: Limit the
number of tabs to five. Having too many
tabs in the bottom navigation can lead
to a cluttered and confusing user
experience. Overloading the space with
excessive options not only makes each
tab smaller and harder to accurately
tap, especially on mobile devices, but
also overwhelms users with too many
choices. This can lead to what's known
as choice paralysis, where users find it
difficult to make a decision because of
the sheer number of options presented to
them. The golden rule, aim for three to
five tabs, max six tabs. This range is
the sweet spot for bottom navigation. It
gives users enough options without
crowding the space. With fewer tabs,
each one has more breathing room, making
them easier to tap and reducing
accidental clicks. This also makes your
app feel more organized and easier to
navigate. Focus on what matters most.
Choose tabs that are essential to your
app's core functions and what users
access most often. This way, your users
have everything they need at their
fingertip without the extra clutter.
Tip: Design thumb friendly tap areas. A
common convention is to use a tap area
that is large enough to be easily tapped
with a thumb. This usually means having
a tap area of at least 44 pixels x 44
pixels. This size is not just a random
choice. It's based on the average size
of a human thumb, which ensures that
most users can comfortably and
accurately tap the navigation items
without accidentally hitting the wrong
one. Why is this important? First, it
improves the overall usability of your
app. Users are likely to navigate using
their thumbs, especially on smaller
devices. A larger tap area reduces the
chance of errors and frustration, making
the app more userfriendly. Second, it
enhances accessibility. Not all users
have the same level of dexterity, and a
generous tap area ensures that the app
is more accessible to people with
varying motor abilities. In contrast, a
smaller tap area, like 24 pixels x 24
pixels, might lead to frequent mistaps
and a poor user experience. Enjoying the
tips so far? That's awesome. But let's
be real, watching a few tips is great,
but what is really going to make a
difference is knowing how to put it all
together. That's where a lot of
designers get stuck. You pick up bits
and pieces, but when you sit down to
design, something still feels off.
That's exactly why we created the UIUX
playbook to give you clear, practical
techniques and real examples that show
you how to design UIs that look clean,
modern, and professional so your work
stands out and looks right every time.
We've had so much amazing feedback from
designers who said that after reading
the playbook, they went from struggling
with designs that just didn't look right
to creating work that looks amazing and
that they're finally proud to share. If
you want to check it out, there's a
special discount for you. Use level up
40 at checkout to get 40% off. And if
you're curious, you can also download a
free preview first. You'll find
everything linked in the description
below. Tip: Differentiate active and
inactive states. Differentiating the
active state in bottom navigation is
essential for creating a clean user
experience. It's about making it
immediately obvious to the user where
they are in the app. A smart way to do
this is to change the style and color of
the active icon. Imagine an icon that
shifts from an outline to a filled
version along with a noticeable change
in color. This visual cue instantly
draws the user's attention to their
current location. To further enhance
this distinction, you can also make the
labeled text for the active icon darker
and thicker. This simple adjustment
reinforces the user's focus on the
active state. The combination of a
transformed icon style, a standout
color, and bolder text works effectively
to differentiate the active tab from the
inactive ones. Conversely, a design that
only alters the text, leaving the icon
unchanged, might not be distinct enough.
In such cases, users might take longer
to identify their current position in
the app, potentially leading to a slower
and more frustrating navigation
experience. It's important to strike a
balance and ensure that the active state
stands out clearly for effortless
navigation. It's also perfectly
acceptable to keep the icon outlined
instead of filling it in as long as you
change its color. The key is to apply at
least two visual changes, such as
adjusting the icon's color and making
the text bolder. This dual change
ensures users can effortlessly
distinguish between active and inactive
tabs, enhancing their navigation
experience in your app. Tip: Choose
simple and familiar icons. When
selecting icons for your bottom
navigation bar, the best approach is to
prioritize familiarity and simplicity.
Choose icons that users can instantly
recognize and that accurately represent
their function. A classic example is
using a magnifying glass for the search
function. It's a universally understood
symbol, making it far more effective
than less familiar options like
binoculars. The simplicity of each icon
is also key. Complex designs or overly
artistic interpretations can confuse
users. The goal is to enable users to
understand and navigate your app with
minimal effort or thought. Simple icons
achieve this by being easy to identify
at a glance. Tip: Keep navigation labels
short and sweet. When it comes to
designing your bottom navigation bar,
less is often more. Opt for concise
single line labels to keep the design
neat and effective. Avoid long labels
that spill over into two lines. They can
clutter the screen and overwhelm your
users. They also tend to make the
navigation bar too big, which can throw
off the balance of your app's layout.
Short labels keep things simple, helping
users make quicker, more instinctive
choices. They also contribute to a
clean, contemporary aesthetic, ensuring
your app is both stylish and functional.
Tip: Keep it clean and simple. A
cluttered or overwhelming design can
hurt the user experience. Avoid adding
unnecessary elements like boxes around
your tabs as these can create visual
noise. Instead, strive for a clean,
minimalist look that guides users
effortlessly through your app. The goal
is to design a navigation bar that's
intuitive and unobtrusive, allowing
users to focus on what matters most, the
content of your app. Tip: Stick to one
icon style except for the selected
state. Mixing filled and outline icons
in the same navigation bar is like
inviting guests to a black tie event
only to have someone show up in
beachwear. To avoid this visual
mismatch, stick to a consistent style of
icons throughout your navigation. If you
decide on outline icons, use them
consistently across all tabs. This
creates a harmonious and visually
balanced look. However, there's a clever
exception, the selected state. here.
Switching an outline icon to a filled
version is a fantastic way to highlight
the active tab. It's like giving that
tab a special badge of honor, making it
stand out in a subtle yet effective way.
Also, be mindful of the complexity of
your icons. Consistency isn't just about
style, it's also about complexity. If
one icon is simple and clean, the others
should follow suit. Mixing a minimal
icon with a more detailed one can throw
off the visual harmony of your
navigation bar. Tip: Avoid using too
many colors. Using too many colors in
your bottom navigation or giving each
tab its own color may seem like a fun
idea, but it usually does more harm than
good. Instead of helping users, it
creates visual chaos. Suddenly,
navigation becomes a guessing game of
colors rather than something that feels
natural and easy. Here's the thing. You
want your navigation to feel like part
of the app, seamless, not loud. When
every tab is a different color, it pulls
attention away from what actually
matters, the content. It can even mess
with your brand's look, making your app
feel less polished and harder to
recognize. The better approach, stick to
your brand's color palette. Keep it
simple and consistent. That way, your
navigation feels clean, your app feels
professional, and your brand stays
strong. Tip: Use notification badges in
bottom navigation to highlight updates.
Using notification badges in your bottom
navigation bar is a great way to signal
new updates or messages to users. These
badges can be simple colored circles, or
they can include numbers to indicate the
quantity of new updates. Badges should
be small enough to stay subtle, but
large enough to be noticeable. Placing
them in the top right corner of the icon
is a common practice, as it's naturally
eye-catching. Here's a pro tip. Adding
an outline around the badge can make it
stand out even more and give it a
polished look. If you're using numbers
within the badge to indicate the count
of new updates, ensure they are easy to
read. Avoid overly small or stylized
fonts that might be hard to decipher at
a glance. Choose a badge color that
stands out against the navigation bar
and icon colors, yet still feels
consistent with the overall app design.
Finally, only use badges for essential
notifications. Overloading users with
badges for every minor update can lead
to notification fatigue, reducing the
effectiveness of this feature. Tip:
Experiment with creative layouts, but
with usability being your priority.
While standard layouts are tried and
tested for usability, stepping outside
the box with a creative and beautiful
design can give your app a distinctive
edge. The key is to strike a balance
between aesthetics and usability. You
can add value to your app by
experimenting with different shapes,
positions, or even dynamic interactions
for your bottom navigation. Maybe you're
thinking about a unique icon arrangement
or an unconventional bar shape. These
creative touches can make your app
memorable. However, here's a word of
caution. Never sacrifice usability for
aesthetics. For instance, while an
unconventional layout may look stunning,
if it confuses users or makes navigation
harder, it can do more harm than good.
All right, let's make this a little bit
more interactive. I want you to pause
the video right now and head to the
comment section. Tell me which bottom
navigation design you like the most. Is
it option A, clean and simple? Option B,
with that sleek line above the active
tab, option C, minimalist with a smooth,
interactive feel, or option D with a
more distinctive custom look. Drop your
favorites in the comments, A, B, C, or
D, and tell me why. I'm curious to see
which style you prefer.
Tip: Separate bottom navigation from
main content. Remember when I mentioned
you should stick around till the end
because there's one big mistake that
even pro designers keep making? Well,
here it is. Not separating the bottom
navigation from the main content. Adding
a subtle soft outline or a one pixel
border around the navigation bar can
create a gentle but clear separation.
This method is unobtrusive yet effective
at visually distinguishing the
navigation area as a distinct element.
Tip: You can use background color to
separate bottom navigation from main
content. Another approach is to
differentiate the background colors of
the bottom navigation and the main
screen. For instance, if your main
screen is white, consider using a light
gray for the navigation bar. This
contrast creates a sense of depth,
making the navigation area feel like a
distinct interactive element of the app.
Using a shadow is also a great way to
achieve this separation. A small soft
shadow above the navigation bar can
create an elevated effect, giving the
impression that the navigation is
floating above the rest of the content.
However, it's important to keep the
shadow subtle. An overly large or harsh
shadow can draw attention away from the
content and detract from the sleekness
of your design. Tip: Choose neutral
colors and avoid using too many colors
in both your top and bottom navigation.
It's best to keep the navigation colors
neutral, such as white, gray, or dark
tones. This approach ensures that the
navigation doesn't distract from the
main content of the app. By reserving
brighter or primary colors for key
actions on the main screen, you help
those elements stand out and draw
attention to what matters most. It's
also important to avoid using too many
different colors between the top and
bottom navigation bars. This can lead to
a disjointed visual experience and
distract users from the app's content.
Keeping a consistent color palette
between these two elements creates a
cohesive and harmonous design. When
choosing colors for your navigation,
it's crucial to consider how they
complement your app's overall theme and
branding. While neutral colors like
white, gray, or dark shades are
generally recommended for their
versatility and subtlety, it's perfectly
fine to opt for a different color if it
enhances your brand's identity. However,
the color should not be so bright or
overpowering that it overwhelms the main
content or disrupts the user's focus. It
should complement the primary colors
used on the main screen, enhancing key
actions and content rather than
competing with them. By the way,
everything that you have learned so far
here is from our UX UI design mastery
course, where we have more than 50
lessons like this one, all designed to
take you from a beginner to a UX UI
design pro. If you want to know more,
the link's in the description. Tip:
Avoid poor contrast for inactive states.
A common pitfall is using poor contrast
for inactive icons and labels, making
them difficult to see or understand,
especially for users with visual
impairments. It's important to strike a
balance between visibility and
distinction. Instead of opting for
drastically different colors, consider
slightly reducing the opacity of
inactive elements. This approach
maintains a cohesive color scheme while
clearly differentiating active and
inactive states. A good starting point
is to aim for an opacity level that is
noticeable yet not too faint. The web
content accessibility guidelines
recommend a minimum contrast ratio of
3:1 for graphical elements and user
interface components. To make sure your
color choices meet accessibility
standards, use tools like the web aim
contrast checker. Tip: Add sleek micro
interactions. Now that you mastered all
important fundamentals and your bottom
navigation bar has a solid base, it's
time to take it completely to the next
level to absolutely delight your users
and make them go, "Wow!" A lot of
beginner designers skip this. Their
bottom navigation is just static. You
tap and it changes, but there's no
feeling. It's like pressing a light
switch with no click. Micro interactions
and smooth transitions make your bottom
navigation feel responsive, polished,
and honestly just more fun to use. Tip
one, tap feedback. When a user taps an
icon, show a quick visual response like
a color change, scale up, or a ripple
effect. Tip two, when switching between
tabs, don't just snap to the next one.
Add a small sliding underline or animate
the icon smoothly into place. Tip three,
transitions between screens. When a user
switches screens, don't make it feel
like they teleported, add a soft fade,
or a sides slide transition. It makes
navigation feel connected. These little
details, they're what separating boring
designs from apps that feel amazing. So,
next time you design a bottom
navigation, don't just make it work,
make it feel great. If you made it all
the way to the end, congratulations. You
now know how to design a perfect bottom
navigation bar. and hopefully your
navigation will never look like this
ever again. I really hope you enjoyed
this video. If you did, it would mean a
lot if you shared it with others. Let's
make every bottom navigation bar out
there awesome. Also, let me know in the
comments which tip was your favorite.
I'd love to hear what you found most
helpful. Thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one. Have an amazing